Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a DASHLANE.
DASHLANE es una herramienta de seguridad todo
en uno, que te permite generar contraseñas
seguras, almacenarlas, guardarte información
personal y de pago, guardar notas de forma
segura, proteger tu privacidad. Todo de forma
rápida y precisa. Ve a DASHLANE.COM/VISUALPOLITIKES
y descárgatelo de forma totalmente gratuíta.
Además, usando el código VISUALPOLITIKES
podrás probar la versión Premium totalmente
gratis durante 30 días. Y luego, además,
si decides continuar con ella, tendrás un
10% de descuento.
Os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale mirarlo
en la Wikipedia… ¿A cuántos inmigrantes
ha deportado Donald Trump? Pensadlo bien:
desde la campaña electoral, Trump nos ha
dejado claro que es inflexible con los inmigrantes.
Que no va a dejar pasar a ningún mexicano
de forma ilegal ¿Verdad? Pues atentos a la
gráfica:
Si os fijáis, veréis que, en lo que a deportaciones
respecta, Obama supera con creces los números
de Trump ¿Significa esto que, en el fondo,
a Trump le gustan los inmigrantes y que se
merece un nóbel de la paz? ¡Por supuesto
que no! Hay muchísimos detalles que podríamos
discutir en esta gráfica. Pero hay una cosa
que nos debería quedar muy clara: cuando
hablamos de inmigración, una cosa son los
hechos y otra las palabras. Y, ahora mismo,
los hechos son los siguientes.
Los inmigrantes en la frontera Sur llegan
a los 100.000 por segundo mes consecutivo
¡Exacto! En estos momentos, el continente
Americano vive una de las mayores crisis de
refugiados de su historia. Cientos de miles
de personas están cruzando todo el territorio
mexicano para llegar a Estados Unidos. Muchos
de ellos son niños que hacen todo el camino
a pie y que llegan en condiciones de malnutrición.
Y sí, habéis oído bien, he dicho que CRUZAN
el territorio mexicano. Porque la mayor parte
de estos inmigrantes o refugiados no viene
de México sino de Centro América. En los
últimos años, países como Honduras, el
Salvador o Guatemala se han convertido en
auténticos infiernos de violencia, narcotráfico
y pobreza extrema.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo ha respondido Donald
Trump a este nuevo desafío? Pues con esto.
Donald Trump amenaza a Mexico con aranceles
del 5% por la inmigración ilegal
Habéis oído bien. Donald Trump quiere pasarle
la patata caliente a México. Que sean ellos
quienes se hagan cargo de todos esos inmigrantes
que cruzan su país. Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué
piensa el gobierno de México al respecto?
Pues bien, el actual presidente mexicano es
este señor que veis aquí: Andrés Manuel
López Obrador. Más conocido por sus siglas,
AMLO. AMLO es un político muy de izquierdas
que, como os podéis imaginar, no tiene ninguna
simpatía por Trump. Durante la campaña electoral
prometió que daría un trato humanitario
a todos los inmigrantes que pasaran por su
país. Pero, por otro lado, México tendría
mucho que perder si su vecino del norte le
impusiera nuevos aranceles. Así que, a AMLO
no le ha quedado más remedio que mandar al
ejército para frenar a todos esos inmigrantes
centroamericanos. Esta es la narrativa que
han comprado casi todos los medios de comunicación:
el malvado Donald Trump ha obligado a México
a maltratar a los inmigrantes para no tener
que hacerlo él mismo. Pero… ¿De verdad
es tan simple? Por ejemplo, tengo una pregunta:
si Estados Unidos no quiere a los inmigrantes
centroamericanos ¿Por qué no se quedan en
México? ¿Cuál es la política de inmigración
de este país? Pues os voy a dar unas cifras
para que os vayáis haciendo una idea. En
EEUU, el 14% de la población son inmigrantes.
La media de la OCDE está en torno al 13%.
Pues bien, en México, la población inmigrante
apenas pasa el 1%. Habéis oído bien. Si
hay un país estricto con los inmigrantes,
ese es México. Pero ¿Cómo funciona exactamente
su política migratoria? ¿Qué está haciendo
México para responder a los inmigrantes y
a los refugiados de Centroamérica? ¿Podemos
hablar de buenos y malos en esta historia=
¿De verdad AMLO está actuando bajo las órdenes
de Trump? ¿O hay algo más? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
LA CARAVANA MIGRANTE
Ya sé lo que estáis pensando ¿Por qué
es ahora cuando vienen tantos inmigrantes
centroamericanos? Seamos honestos, Honduras,
Guatemala o El Salvador nunca han sido países
especialmente prósperos. Pero si algo nos
enseña la historia es que si algo va mal,
siempre puede ir a peor. Entre 2010 y 2012,
las cifras de criminalidad se dispararon en
toda la zona. En 2009, Honduras sufre un golpe
de Estado y El Salvador tiene que hacer frente
a las Maras, que son bandas callejeras ultraviolentas.
Algo similar ocurre en Guatemala. Este fenómeno
se explica, en parte, por el narcotráfico.
En los años 80, la violencia de los narcos
estaba concentrada, principalmente, en Colombia.
Eran los tiempos de Pablo Escobar, el cartel
de Cali y las FARC. Pero a partir de los años
2000, Colombia consiguió sofocar la violencia.
Como explicábamos en vídeos anteriores,
el país de Maluma y Alvinsch sigue siendo
uno de los principales productores de coca
del mundo pero los distintos carteles han
llegado a una especie de Pax mafiosa. Así
que ahora, todas esas guerrillas se han trasladado
a Centro América. También hay quien culpa
al cambio climático. Según esta teoría,
el cambio climático está ocasionando sequías
en Centroamérica. Y si el campo no es productivo,
la gente se muere de hambre y tiene que marcharse.
A todo esto hay que sumarle las organizaciones
de refugiados. Por ejemplo, Pueblos sin Fronteras
es una ONG con sede en Chicago que está organizando
caravanas migrantes, lo que llaman el VIA
CRUCIS del MIGRANTE. Ellos se encargan de
ofrecer apoyo logístico para que miles de
refugiados puedan emprender su camino. Pero
no sólo hablamos de ONGs sino también de
auténticas mafias que se dedican al tráfico
de personas.
Sea cual sea la explicación, lo cierto es
que hablamos de todo un éxodo. Para que os
hagáis una idea, en el año 2007, las patrullas
fronterizas de Estados Unidos capturaron a
16.000 guatemaltecos que cruzaban la frontera.
11 años más tarde, en 2018, la cifra sube
a 115.000 guatemaltecos.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Son inmigrantes o refugiados?
Pues lo cierto es que, en honor a la verdad,
deberíamos hablar de refugiados. Oficialmente,
se les sigue considerando migrantes pero…
seamos honestos, en la mayor parte de los
casos, no hablamos de gente ambiciosa que
quiere probar suerte en el país de las oportunidades.
En realidad, son personas que están escapando
de la violencia extrema. Muchos son niños
y mujeres que han sido amenazados por alguna
mara salvadoreña, por ejemplo, y saben que
les van a matar si regresan. Eso explica por
qué están dispuestos a lo que sea con tal
de dejar su país. Y bien digo, lo que sea.
La ruta que va desde Guatemala hasta El Paso,
en Estados Unidos, tiene más de 3000 kilómetros.
Pues bien, mucha gente la hace andando. Otros
a través a través del llamado “tren de
la muerte”. Ya os podéis imaginar por qué
lo llaman así.
¿Y qué pasa cuando llegan a Estados Unidos?
Pues que la mayoría de estos refugiados son
deportados ¡Pero también hay algunos afortunados
que logran quedarse! En los últimos años,
las autoridades estadounidenses han sacado
programas especiales de integración para
toda esta gente. Sólo en el año 2017, más
de 59.000 centroamericanos consiguieron quedarse
en el país ¿Os parecen muchos? ¿Os parecen
pocos? Eso lo dejo a vuestra opinión. Pero
lo cierto es que el gobierno de México ha
acogido a muchísima menos gente. Para que
os hagáis una idea, en este momento, hay
más de 900.000 guatemaltecos viviendo en
Estados Unidos. En México son poco más de
50.000.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué? ¿Por qué
los centroamericanos no se pueden quedar a
vivir en México? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver.
NO ES PAÍS PARA EXTRANJEROS
En México lo tienen muy claro: no todos los
inmigrantes son iguales. Por ejemplo, si estáis
viendo este vídeo desde España y sois blancos
de clase media… ¡Tranquilos! México os
recibe con los brazos abiertos. No vais a
tener casi ningún problema en conseguir el
visado. Para que os hagáis una idea, México
sólo tiene algo más de 1 millón de inmigrantes,
lo que supone menos del 1%. Pues bien, atentos
a la gráfica.
De ese millón de inmigrantes, 900.000 son
estadounidenses, 27.000 vienen de España
y sólo 15.000 vienen de Honduras. Hay más
alemanes viviendo en México que Salvadoreños.
Y esto es sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta
que El Salvador está cerca y habla el mismo
idioma.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué ocurre esto?
¿Es casualidad? La respuesta es no. Mirad
lo que dice la ley de inmigración mexicana.
“La Secretaría de Gobernación podrá negar
a los extranjeros la entrada al país o el
cambio de calidad o característica migratoria
cuando lo exija el equilibrio demográfico
nacional”
¡Habéis oído bien! Eso del equilibrio demográfico
nacional es una forma bonita de decir: no
queremos gente de países pobres. Pero ya
sé lo que me vais a decir. Los que veáis
este vídeo desde México sabéis que las
cosas están cambiando. En Octubre de 2018,
el Gobierno de México lanzó este mensaje.
“Hoy México te extiende la mano: Queremos
que tú y todos los migrantes se sientan tranquilos
y protegidos. Para apoyarte, México está
lanzando el día de hoy el plan “estás
en tu casa”. Estando en México podrás
recibir atención médica, incluso mandar
a tus hijos a la escuela. También tendrás
una identificación oficial temporal para
hacer los trámites que necesites mientras
regularizas tu situación migratoria”
El señor que habéis visto en la pantalla
es Enrique PEÑA NIETO, el ex presidente de
México. Una de sus últimas medidas antes
de dejar el gobierno fue este plan llamado
“estás en tu casa”. El sucesor de Peña
Nieto, AMLO, estaba de acuerdo con este plan.
Y Donald Trump también estaba contento. De
repente, México daba un giro de 180º a su
política migratoria. Y eso significa que
Estados Unidos le podía pasar la patata caliente
a su vecino del Sur.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no todo es
tan bonito! Efectivamente, el Gobierno mexicano,
primero con Peña Nieto y luego con AMLO acogió
a miles de refugiados. En sólo unos meses,
más de 10.000 guatemaltecos, hondureños
y salvadoreños decidieron quedarse en territorio
mexicano. Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué pensaban
los mexicanos al respecto? Pues… nada bueno.
58% de los mexicanos rechaza que se permita
entrar a migrantes: encuesta
Efectivamente: Trump no es el único que no
quiere ver refugiados ni en pintura. A esto
hay que sumarle el hecho de que las autoridades
mexicanas están no dan abasto con tantísimos
inmigrantes y refugiados. Pensadlo bien: alguien
tiene que dar todos esos certificados oficiales,
construir albergues y ayudar a que los centroamericanos
encuentren trabajo. Todo eso cuesta dinero.
Y compromiso político. Y AMLO, que juró
su cargo en diciembre de 2018 no quiere arriesgar
sus altísimos niveles de popularidad. Así
que, con la policía y el ejército desbordados
y la sociedad en contra de abrir las puertas
a los extranjeros, el nuevo presidente no
quiere hacer experimentos.
México triplica las deportaciones de migrantes
centroamericanos con López Obrador
El nuevo Gobierno ha expulsado a más de 45.000
personas en cinco meses, casi 15.000 de ellas
en abril
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cuál es la consecuencia
de esta política migratoria? Por supuesto,
las mayores damnificados son los cientos de
miles de centroamericanos que no pueden quedarse
ni en México ni en Estados Unidos. Pero esta
no es la única consecuencia. Pensadlo bien,
si AMLO no quiere acoger a los refugiados
¿A dónde se van? ¡Exacto! Continúan su
ruta hacia la frontera estadounidense. En
otras palabras, que la patata caliente vuelve
a las manos de Donald Trump. Estamos ya en
mayo del año 2019. Y es en este momento cuando
la Casa Blanca amenaza a México con aranceles
del 5% a sus exportaciones. En otras palabras,
que AMLO se ve entre la espada y la pared.
Si acoge a todos los inmigrantes tiene un
problema enorme, tanto económico como de
popularidad. Pero si no los acoge, tiene un
problema enorme con Estados Unidos. En esta
tesitura ¿Cuál es la única solución posible?
Pues esta.
El programa estadounidense “quéndense en
México” se expande dejando a más gente
en una peligrosa ciudad mexicana.
En otras palabras, que en mayo de 2019, Trump
le dijo a AMLO “A ver, México, chavalote…
me da igual cómo lo consigas pero no quiero
ver a más centroamericanos en mi frontera
¿Quieres quedártelos? Todos tuyos ¿Quieres
deportarlos? Pues los deportas. Pero eh! Como
vea a un inmigrante más cruzando mi frontera,
te pongo unos aranceles que te vas a cagar”
¿Y cual es la solución más rápida para
AMLO? Pues básicamente, dejar que los inmigrantes
se queden en una serie de guetos muy concretos.
México ha desplegado a más de 6000 soldados
de la guardia nacional para contener a todos
los centroamericanos. Es decir, que no se
les deporta pero tampoco se les deja avanzar
ni mucho menos integrarse en la sociedad.
Por ejemplo, en los últimos meses, miles
de personas están concentradas en ciudades
como NUEVO LAREDO, en la frontera norte, en
condiciones infrahumanas. No hay médicos,
a duras penas hay comida y la criminalidad
está creciendo a ritmos acelerados. Pero
sin duda alguna, la ciudad que más problemas
tiene es TAPACHULA, en el estado de CHIAPAS.
Tapachula es la primera ciudad mexicana nada
más cruzas la frontera con Guatemala. En
esta ciudad se han registrado entre 20.000
y 30.000 solicitudes de asilo. El ejército
mexicano está en la frontera conteniendo
a los flujos de migrantes. Y ya se han registrado
asesinatos por parte de maras salvadoreñas
y toda clase de bandas violentas. En otras
palabras, que todos esos refugiados que han
terminado en la misma situación de la que
estaban escapando. Es cierto que Estados Unidos
no les quiere. Pero, seamos honestos, México
tampoco. Y mientras ambos países se pasan
la patata caliente, miles de personas están
viviendo un auténtico infierno.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Cómo creéis que se puede solucionar este
problema? ¿Creéis que México podría hacer
algo más para acoger a todos esos refugiados?
¿Creéis que Estados Unidos debería dar
ayudas económicas para que México puede
hacer frente a tantos refugiados? ¿O tal
vez deberían llegar a un acuerdo para compartir
responsabilidades? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios.
DASHLANE es una herramienta de seguridad,
todo en uno, que incluye un VPN para todos
tus dispositivos, de tal forma que puedas
usar redes públicas de manera segura y anónima.
Seguro que a ti, al igual que a mí, también
te preocupa tu privacidad en la red. Pues
bien, con DASHLANE mantendrás tu identidad
online segura. DASHLANE te protegerá de todo
tipo de amenazas contra tu identidad. Ya sabes
que hay muchos hackers ahí fuera pensando
en cómo aprovecharse de ti. Y la mejor forma
de esquivarlos es utilizando DASHLANE. También
hacen una cosa muy interesante que se llama
monitoreo de la Dark web, que consiste en
escanear la web en busca de datos personales
filtrados o robados, alertándote al instante
en caso de que tus datos personales se encuentren
donde no deben. De esta forma, puedes tomar
medidas rápidamente. Y, por supuesto, DASHLANE
te ayudará a generar contraseñas seguras
y, cada vez que la web te pida introducirlas,
te ayudará a rellenar los campos requeridos
de forma rápida y sencilla. Es super cómodo.
Se acabó eso de no acordarte de las contraseñas.
Como os decía antes Dashlane es totalmente
gratuíta… epro hay algunas opciones Premium
en casa de que quieras disponer de más servicios.
Bien, si entras en DASHLANE.COM/VISUALPOLITIKES,
usando el código VISUALPOLITIKES, tendrás
una prueba de esas opciones Premium totalmente
gratis durante 30 días. Si, después, además,
decides continuar con ellas, obtendrás in
10% de descuento a la hora de contratarlas.
No lo dudes, hazme caso y entra en el link
que te dejamos en la descripción y descárgate
DASHLANE de forma gratuíta. No te arrepentiras.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.